طفل يعاني من صعوبة في التنفس ولهذا السبب
أخذت هذه الأم في كولومبوس بولاية أوهايو طفلها
البالغ من العمر شهرين إلى المستشفى الذي
رفضه بسرعة فائقة
الأطباء في جميع أنحاء البلاد يحذرون
من تهديد ثلاثي ، وهو ثلاثة
فيروسات يطلق عليها طبيب واحد بالتأكيد
نعلم جميعًا  حول فيروس كورونا نحن
نعرف بالتأكيد عن الأنفلونزا ولكن RSV معروف مرة أخرى من
قبل كل طبيب أطفال لأنه
يملأ مستشفياتنا كل عام RSV أو
فيروس حساس للجهاز التنفسي وهو
مرض تنفسي شائع يكون في بعض الأحيان
شديدًا عند الرضع والأطفال الصغار
يقول الخبراء إن RSV والإنفلونزا
تضربان.  في وقت سابق من هذا العام عما
يفعلون عادةً إذا نظرت في جنوب
الولايات المتحدة ، بدأنا بالفعل في
رؤية حالات الإنفلونزا تأخذ قفزة كبيرة
جدًا ، لذا فنحن قلقون قليلاً
بشأن هذا التداخل بين كل
هذه الفيروسات المختلفة لأنه عادةً
يأتي RSV بعد ذلك بقليل ثم
تأتي الأنفلونزا بشكل جيد للغاية بعد أن يأخذوا
دورهم في عدد حالات RSV
في الولايات المتحدة التي تم اكتشافها بواسطة اختبارات PCR في t  كان
الأسبوع الثاني من شهر أكتوبر أعلى من
أي أسبوع آخر في العامين الماضيين
وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض ، وفي جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، يستخدم حوالي ثلاثة أرباع
أسرة مستشفيات الأطفال
حاليًا حصة هواء أكبر مما كانت عليه في أي وقت
خلال العامين الماضيين.
لديك أكثر من 90 في المائة من تلك الأسرة
قيد الاستخدام الآن في مين رود آيلاند
وديلاوير في هذه المدرسة الثانوية في
مقاطعة ستافورد بولاية فيرجينيا ، كان ما يقرب من نصف الجسم الطلابي
خارجًا في وقت ما الأسبوع الماضي
بأعراض تشبه أعراض الأنفلونزا وبعد السقوط
لأشهر ظهرت الحالات المرغوبة  لقد تم
تسويتها مؤخرًا في الولايات المتحدة
، سأكون صادقًا ، أعتقد أننا نمر
بعدة أشهر صعبة ، حيث نرى
أعدادًا كبيرة من الأطفال الذين يمرضون
ويحتاجون بالفعل إلى الدعم
للتكاثر وقد رأينا قبل
المواسم التي توقعناها  لدى RSV والإنفلونزا
أعراض مشابهة يقول الخبراء إن سيلان الأنف
ينخفض ​​في الشهية ، سعال ، عطس ،
حمى صفير ، لذلك ليس من السهل
دائمًا معرفة المرض الذي يعاني منه طفلك وقد
يكون من الصعب عليه  معرفة ما إذا كان
يجب عليك إحضارهم إلى المستشفى ، فربما
يكون لديهم استنشاق واحتقان السعال
ولكنهم بخير في المنزل أو أن
طفلك يكافح حقًا أو يعمل من
أجل التنفس بحيث يحتاجون إلى القدوم
لرؤيتنا في المستشفى وفي
قسم الطوارئ ، ماذا عن الرضع
وحديثي الولادة الذين لا يستطيعون إخبار
والديهم بما يشعرون به ،
يجب ألا
يرفض هؤلاء الآباء زجاجة الرضاعة ، وغالبًا ما تكون هذه
واحدة من أولى العلامات التي نلاحظ أن الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي
يخرج عن نطاق السيطرة عند هؤلاء
الأطفال  عندما يبدأون في رفض الزجاجة الخاصة بهم ،
تبدأ في مواجهة مشكلة في إيقاظهم
، الأطباء الذين تحدثنا معهم للحصول على
هذه النصيحة لأولياء أمور الأطفال الصغار
بشأن التدابير الوقائية
ضد الأنفلونزا RSV وتريد غسل يديك في
كثير من الأحيان يجب على الجميع تغطية أفواههم
عند السعال  أو تعطس وارتداء الأقنعة إذا كانت
لديك أعراض ، وعلى الرغم من
عدم وجود لقاح ضد
الفيروس المخلوي التنفسي ، فهناك لقاحات ضد الإنفلونزا ، ويمكنك الحصول
عليها للأطفال حتى سن ستة أشهر
قديما والآن هو وقت مهم للحصول عليهم
بريان تود سي إن إن واشنطن